so what we're describing here is the sum
of an what do we call this thing an
arithmetic progression which is
progression is just going to be our word
for like a bunch of things together in
an order right so you often get these
called a P's no relationship to the
exams okay so there's some of an
arithmetic progression we can say this
in two ways the way I just showed you
I'm gonna say the sum of n terms so I'm
gonna put that in down in a sort of
subscript okay what it equals to is
first how many columns did we end up
with well it comes from how many terms
you had in your arithmetic progression
so we called that in right just because
it's convenient and because I don't like
writing long fraction lines that
division by two i'm gonna chuck it out
the front here okay and then what do I
multiply that by what is each column how
tall is each column its it was in our in
our example as 1 plus 11 but generally
speaking it's the first term a plus the
last term L okay
now what I want to do is push on this a
little bit and I want to recognize the
fact that you guys have a name for this
right think back to last lesson the last
term if you've got a UH if you've got a
series of yeah a bunch of terms right we
would call the last term turn n right
like term twenty or twenty fifty
depending on how long your series is
right
what's our expression for that what can
we call this nth term we have a formula
for that do you remember what it was
think think you got it you always start
with the first term plus what do we add
on to that very good now why is it n
minus one it's it's how many terms along
you are you take away one because you're
not counting the first term and then you
multiply that by that common difference
that we outlined before okay so if this
is what L is then I can just like
substitute that in and I've got like
ends and aids and stuff that will
actually sort of simplify
a little bit so I can say the same thing
the some of that arithmetic progression
I can also say it like so and on to
that's still at the front and then in
here I'm going to write actually I'm
gonna use a square bracket because I've
got brackets in brackets you a there's
the first term and here comes the last
term I'll write it in the red so you can
highlight it and see right the last term
is a plus and minus one lots of the
common difference that's a yeah very
good so this just a teeny teeny bit of
collective like terms yeah so this is
the way we could simplify it okay
now you will use both of these okay so
we've got our first one our first one
here this is nice and succinct you've
got this one which is a little fancier
but it's kind of handy if you don't
necessarily know what the last term is
you just know I want to do this many
terms I don't even know what the last
term is but if you tell me it's xx one I
can still use this formula okay so as an
example let's go with that series that
we just did before that was the sum of
the first n odd numbers so let's do a
little subheading here okay so if I
wanted to work out we were doing yeah
yeah go ahead please thank you
we did six six odd numbers to begin with
but you know let's do something a little
more ambitious because we can actually
do a bigger amount this now we have a
formula for it so I'm gonna work out
what is the sum of the first 15 odd
numbers now this will actually take some
mucking around to do okay how would I
use this formula to help me with that
well let's think about this how many how
many terms are I gonna have I'm gonna
have 15 right so I'm gonna write write a
bit outset there's my n on to okay so
far so good now I do this part in the
middle so to lots of the first term or
what's the first number it's just one so
I'm gonna write two lots of one and now
you probably could have just gone
straight to two but you guys know I
really think it's helpful to put the
substitutions too
and make it explicit plus I've got n
minus one again I did the N already it's
15 so I'm gonna go 15 minus 1 and what's
the difference between each of the odd
numbers it's too wide I do wonder you
talk about this one here yeah - lots of
what what is a represent again we chose
a because the first term it's the first
term which in this case happens to be
one yeah and then that's it I caused my
bracket okay now let's just quickly have
a go at this mmm
seven and a half times what do we got
here two plus that's 14 times two which
is 28 28 14 times 2 is 28 so I've got 30
in here 30 lots of seven and a half does
anyone tell me what that is seven seven
and a half times three that's 210 plus
15 225 now by the way 225 fun fact 225
is not just a random number it's a
special number
it's a square of 15 I chose this example
because here's the way you can show it
by the way the sum of the first n odd
numbers is just n squared look I'll
prove it ok here is the first odd number
which is the first square number agreed
what's the next odd number it's three
right now I could do it as a vertical
column like I showed you before but I'm
gonna do a little differently do you
agree that this is another way to
represent three your brains like oh my
gosh so this is one plus three right
which is equal to 4 which is 2 squared
what's the next side number five which I
could do as a column but rather than do
as a column I'm gonna represent it
wrapping around like this there's my 5
which is 3 squared so you can see why
are we interested in arithmetic
progressions there are so many beautiful
patterns that you find in there ok now
real quick we just saw how to use this
when is this useful when you know how
many terms and where you start right
when is this one useful yeah it's when
you sometimes you get handed the last
term they're like oh I'm just gonna end
on eleven like the example I showed you
before you don't need to go through all
of this small work
just tell me 11 and off you go okay